foreign
as a person of faith
I look at this money thing through the
lens of a Biblical method of living
now you don't have to and you and I can
be friends but that's what I do and so I
love the quote when it comes to
financial Independence
that Bob gas said
the guy from the Northeast a preacher oh
Pentecostal preacher guy he said the
definition of prosperity
is having the money to do God's will in
your life
yes so if you are living on the mission
field and
a third world country
it doesn't take a lot of money to pull
that off you don't need 300 000 a year
and if that if you're living on the
mission field and if that's God's will
for your life let's just let's assume it
is
and you've got the the mission work is
funded where your family can eat you
have reasonable safety reasonable
shelter while you're doing the mission
work but you're in a situation where it
doesn't require a lot of money to do in
quotes God's will for your life
then you are prosperous
you are very prosperous by definition
if you are called to
uh run some massive thing it might be
millions and millions of dollars to run
so that that's that's God's will he's
asking you to do that
and so the way one of the things I do
around here is I judge the stuff we do
at Ramsey okay is this project this
thing we're getting ready to launch this
new brand this new effort this new
whatever is that God's will is he
wanting to do it and one of the ways we
can ascertain that is if we have the
money to do it that's right if we don't
have the money to do it then it must not
be at least not yet because apparently
he owns all the money and so if he wants
that done
and wants me to do it put on it won't be
Bank of America that's funding it I sure
hope not it'll be it'll be the money
will be here and it won't show up
mysteriously he'll give us the way to
make the profit to do it yeah might show
up mysteriously but that's so bad
happens very rare and that's why they
call it Miracle because it's seldom yeah
and I haven't really lived my life for a
miracle to Miracle I've lived my life
from production to production but God
gave me two hands of Mind a work ethic
energy
yeah you Boundless Energy to work pray
like it all depends on God work like it
all depends on you exactly and so
um
you know when you're talking about
financial Independence
you need to think about independent from
what
because I've never I I believe in
becoming wealthy but I don't know if you
ever really become independent
as a matter of fact you might become
more dependent because I'm convinced the
more stuff you own the more repairmen
you have to know
I mean you're you're more interdependent
the bigger your footprint is more money
mo problems yeah yeah it is in that
sense or more responsibility yeah for
sure you know and so more you know and
you see things you never saw before you
feel a responsibility towards uh folk
that that are struggling that you never
felt before because you're able to to do
something about it and um so you know
I I don't know much about this fire
movement but if it if it has to do with
I want to pile up a bunch of money so I
don't have to do anything yes then
that's the exact opposite of what we
teach it's all tied into that minimal
Monday I don't want to work it's all
tied together in that if you hate your
job and that that's where you should
change jobs that's where the Crux is you
should go to Ken coleman.com and get a
different job get something do work that
has meaning yeah because if you hit your
job of course you want it I'm gonna work
15 years of my life and completely burn
the candle at both ends or something I
hate with people I hate in a toxic
environment to pile up enough cash to
escape when I could have just quit yeah
and I mean these people with the fire
movement their sacrifice I mean the
amount that they're putting into
Investments I mean they're living on a
quarter of their income they're putting
so much it it's okay but I'm saying you
know after before you retire you're not
gonna get free no you don't get free
this out of Heaven I mean you don't get
free you you all you do is you're going
to move from one thing to the next thing
is all and so this idea I'm going to be
independent now you can be independent
of having to work for a jerk yes but
that requires keeping your lifestyle low
and your assets up and I I think really
the Crux of that is when you when we
talk about this all the time when you
become debt free it does change the way
you work because you're no longer
working simply because you have to pay
bills simply because you have to prop up
a lifestyle you start to decide what you
really enjoy doing what you'd really
like to spend your time doing what you
what matters to you putting your effort
towards and that is something that I
think is very Noble
um as opposed to just saying I don't
want to work anymore right yeah I I so I
can get I can come alongside sacrificing
to win I can come alongside piling up a
big old pile of assets
uh prospering yep I can come alongside
becoming successful financially I'll you
know to the extent you want to do that
you got me on your team you got the
Ramsay folks on your team but I will
tell you as an old guy you're not going
to become independent
you're going to discover it's quite the
opposite that you're more interdependent
than ever before you cannot Escape if
you're not the Unabomber and even he
didn't Escape okay so you you really
aren't you know this this mythology I'm
going to pile up a bunch of cash and
move to Costa Rica and nobody's ever
going to see me again yeah but you have
no humans in your life right that know
you and love you where's your family
where's your friends where's your
history you're just gonna go live in a
foreign country where no one knows who
you are all by your lonesome self that's
called mental illness
okay
I mean really
human beings need long deep gratifying
relationships and wealth is not to
escape from that it's to embrace that
it's very good and to accentuate that
and so this idea that you're somehow
going to be independent that you're not
going to have to have any problems or
any people to deal with it's quite the
opposite let me tell you what wealth
does a hundred percent of the time it
magnifies you
it makes you more of what you already
are
so if you're kind
you're going to become unbelievably kind
if you're a generous person you're going
to become what we call a philanthropist
if you are have a problem with anger God
help the people in your life if you get
money
God help them
if you are a crook and you get money
you're going to do crook on steroids man
you're gonna do whatever you do you get
money you're gonna do it big you want to
know what but there's part of that too
with this retirement thing because if
you are that person if you're a generous
person if you have a servant heart if
you are a person who loves helping up
it's going to be hard for you to not
work well because you're going to want
to do more you're going to want to do
more so in other words I'll I get a
whole lot more personal spiritual
emotional mental health satisfaction out
of doing the show out of meeting someone
two couples who just paid off their
house at the break right I get more out
of that than I do income yeah there's no
income that offsets that meaning so if
you cannot Escape man's need for meaning
that's right uh Victor frankl's book
Man's Search for meaning I read it 25
years ago and I just read it again the
other day and it was like it was brand
new it was long enough long enough ago
that I read it that I think I forgot the
whole thing but Man's Search for meaning
but it doesn't come in a pile of assets
so you're not going to get enough assets
to not have a need to produce something
for the good of others that is that is
innate in you it is part of your DNA you
do not get to escape Society because of
wealth quite the opposite quite the
opposite so don't look for financial
Independence look for some Financial
Security not pure security there's no
way you get enough to ever be 100 secure
but uh but but
you know but but look for I'm going to
have an uh where I don't worry about the
money for a bag of Doritos right I mean
I don't have to worry about that one
less thing and you know I look for some
security look for the ability to change
your family tree look for the ability to
be unreasonably generous look for the
ability for your wealth to create enough
income that you don't have to work
that's right you want to then work
anyway yes doing something
wow I didn't even thought about that
stuff in a while yeah